this was a bit late start welcome to
this video against a legend a legend
from the US okay shrine money for again
who is playing the delayed co-ceo an
interesting line i recently got a sorry
got a book about this opening where they
claim that this move honor that he chose
is not so great because of Bishop e3 I
don't really know I don't really know
much more i only know exactly that but
he is already doing something here what
about can i maybe open up the whole
thing here with some sort of a gambit
play or he might ignore idea with Jesus
acts or something he's not ignoring it
but ok now I have a really nice
development so hmm 25 ok I can go
come on I have to know h4 know this is a
I have to want it to go h4 of course not
h3y and now we as a position yeah
otherwise h4 h5 would be really
dangerous I don't really believe this
one bit what you played age three what
is it was a joke okay let's do it the
tempo down unbeliever h3 great great
mouth slip
yeah it's it's obviously not the same
thing but oh come on I have to do
something crazy now h3 is so ridiculous
I think that after h4 I have a really
good compensation if not something's
really wrong in chess ok I have to I can
only check it afterwards you can take
Rukia this is this is no just correct
for whites to be honest I can maybe I
get in Long castles or something
yeah I know if he takes you three I mean
this is like Swiss cheese but I have to
to do something drastic okay your texts
III now Jim okay
the problem is that that 94 is the
problem a little bit this is exchanges
like everything I mean not everything
but really a lot
yeah maybe I get some summer chances to
22 true cameo in the Kings side it's
never ever correct or anything but maybe
some practical chances
now if I go h4 immediately simply
doesn't get to Castle that easily this
is the issue okay so what exactly is
this move doing I don't know I want to
get an e5 and f5
g5 takes f5 bishop moves something like
that it's probably nothing but or just
bishop truth is c3 would also be quite
nice but the tattoo how to accomplish
change
maybe maybe a useful to get the rook
here but it's still nothing serious
let's attack so we five now maybe you
five takes things it doesn't matter
really check now I decided decided on
that very quickly probably justifiably
so but still pawn takes pawn takes Queen
back Bishop age six at least and here f5
as possible the bad thing is he can just
take here and now e5 hangs and Bishop
age 625 is not helping me at all hmm so
I have to do this on d takes Bishop h6
fishing of course but check
I don't know there's still some chances
with f6 or something or aged 6 I mean a
hive law lost against less dangerous and
text not taking this of course trying to
attack the ship h4 looks like that I
want to mate on g7 it's not so easy I
mean this the computer will probably win
very easily but for a human I don't see
it at the moment something like that
yeah maybe the shop age for he will take
so probably more firepower is helpful
yeah I thought what you to simply
covering this Bishop age 7 nah yeah this
is I will I will surprisingly win this
wouldn't have thought that this is the
possible but the tech was was quite
what's quite strong and all of a sudden
check checkmate yeah I mean I don't know
h3 is of course total total joke yeah
this is this is of course what I wanted
and while while I'm not saying that it
wins or anything but it's better than
age three so probably d6 yes and I
thought age 595 I mean they have some I
have compensation but it's probably not
as good as I thought yes Jim it's still
fairly solid he has lost some time but
hmm h4 h5 didn't net that much yeah well
h3 is of course totally ridiculous what
is the computer actually giving castles
or queen d 5 with with compensation 25
to h5 yeah that that's that's quite
interesting I thought about that but I
wasn't really sure what the queen is
doing on d5 but it can go here yeah just
for for development yeah this is some
compensation the Queen can go here and
then night to d5 it's quite nice
actually yeah this is what I should do
and h3 is of course utterly ridiculous
but okay I have to I have to play for me
for some some tricks now he's winning
i'm not arguing here i just wonder Oh f6
and I'm winning oh I should have seen
that one boom what good hmm f6 king
queen here bishop age six and resigns
chim chim I'm still lost check but step
by step it it's our turn in my favor
efore still wins with this no losses
yeah it was it wasn't easy practical
practical point of view not easy at all
of them okay thanks for watching